[HOST]: Hey, Mira, I recently saw a statistic that absolutely stunned me. Do you know how much a single transistor costs these days?
[MIRA]: Hmm, How much?
[HOST]: It's roughly one five-billionth of what it cost back in 1970. One five-billionth! When I first saw that number, my immediate thought was, Wow, technological progress is truly insane. It's almost incomprehensible, isn't it? To think that something so fundamental to modern electronics has become so incredibly cheap.
[MIRA]: Yes, the cost reduction curve for semiconductors is arguably one of the most remarkable stories in human industrial history. We're talking about performance doubling every year or two, while the cost simultaneously plummets. When you encounter a figure like that, it's natural to feel a sense of awe, to think, This is the sheer power of exponential growth in action. It's a testament to sustained innovation, relentless engineering, and the compounding effects of learning and scale.
[HOST]: Absolutely, that's exactly what I thought. But then, almost immediately, I stumbled upon another statistic that completely threw me off. The inflation-adjusted cost per square foot of residential construction in the United States is more expensive now than it was fifty years ago. More expensive! That just felt fundamentally wrong to me. How can two such critical areas of human endeavor move in such diametrically opposed directions? It's like living in two different economic realities simultaneously.
[MIRA]: Hmm, you've zeroed in on an absolutely critical comparison. We have two distinct industries, both attracting enormous amounts of capital and some of the brightest minds. Yet, one has seen its costs drop by a factor of hundreds of thousands, if not millions, while the other has actually seen its costs increase. This isn't just a slight difference in decimal points， these are two trends moving in entirely opposite directions, signaling a deeper, more fundamental divergence in their underlying economic dynamics. It challenges many of our intuitive assumptions about progress and efficiency.
[HOST]: And it's not like we haven't been trying to make building more efficient, right? I mean, we've had prefabricated housing concepts for over a century now. New techniques, new materials ， they're constantly being developed and introduced. Japan, for instance, has embraced architectural deregulation more thoroughly than almost any other Western nation, explicitly trying to lower housing costs and stimulate innovation. And what's been the result? Costs are still going up. It's baffling. It makes you question whether our efforts are even pointed in the right direction, or if there's some unseen force at play.
[MIRA]: Precisely. And this is exactly why I find the conventional explanations insufficient. If you ask most people why building a house is becoming more expensive, they'll typically cite factors like excessive regulation, the Not In My Back Yard phenomenon, escalating labor costs, or perhaps insufficient investment in research and development. And it's true, these factors do exist, and they do contribute to cost. But the problem is, even if you systematically address every single one of those issues, the fundamental cost curve for housing still doesn't bend significantly downwards. Japan's experience, with its aggressive deregulation and innovative approaches, serves as a powerful, real-world proof point for this argument. It shows that these common explanations, while valid in isolation, don't capture the entire picture.
[HOST]: Wait, let me just process that for a moment. So, you're implying that this isn't just an isolated issue affecting a specific industry or two? This isn't just about the idiosyncrasies of construction or healthcare?
[MIRA]: Correct. This is not an individual industry's isolated problem. This represents a fundamental, structural dividing line running through the economy. Some industries are inherently positioned to capture and ride the wave of exponential cost reduction, while others, by their very nature, simply cannot. It doesn't matter how much capital you pour into them, or how many brilliant minds you assign to the task. The core issue isn't about who's working harder or smarter， it's about why certain industries are able to board the exponential growth express train, while others can't even purchase a ticket, despite their best efforts. This distinction is far more profound than commonly understood.
[HOST]: Wow. As soon as you frame the question like that, I know this episode is going to be incredibly insightful and worth every minute. So, what's the answer you propose in your work? Where exactly do you draw this dividing line? What is this fundamental distinction that explains such a massive economic divergence?
[MIRA]: My answer is that this line is drawn in a place you might not immediately expect. It's not a distinction between digital and physical goods. It's not about the presence or absence of regulation, nor is it simply a divide between public and private sectors. Instead, it's rooted in a much older concept, one borrowed from language philosophy， the distinction between type and token. It might sound highly academic, I know, but I promise that I will explain precisely why this particular distinction possesses such remarkable predictive power, enabling us to anticipate the cost trajectories of virtually every industry.
[HOST]: Alright, you've definitely got me hooked now. But before we dive into type and token, I want to clarify a more foundational question. What are the specific conditions required for exponential cost reduction to occur? In your article, you used a term that really stuck with me， factory logic. Can you elaborate on that?
[MIRA]: Yes, I indeed call it factory logic. And to be clear, this doesn't necessarily mean there must be a physical factory building involved. Rather, it refers to a set of underlying conditions that industries capable of achieving exponential cost reduction universally fulfill，conditions that mirror the highly optimized and repeatable processes found in a traditional factory setting. There are four key conditions in total.
[HOST]: Okay, let's break them down one by one. I'm ready.
[MIRA]: The first condition is identical inputs . This means that whether you're manufacturing the first unit or the one-millionth unit, the raw materials and components you use are essentially the same. There's consistency in the fundamental building blocks. The second condition is a reproducible process . This implies that the method you employ to create the one-millionth unit is identical to the method you used for the very first one. The steps, the sequence, the machinery ， all are perfectly repeatable.
[HOST]: Hmm, those two make a lot of sense. They seem quite intuitive for mass production. What about the third condition?
[MIRA]: The third condition is that the learning curve must be transferable . This means that the experience and knowledge gained from producing, say, the hundredth unit can be directly and fully applied to the production of the hundred-and-first unit. Each iteration allows for the accumulation of valid, actionable experience, and critically, this experience isn't wasted or lost， it builds upon itself cumulatively. You get better and faster over time, and that improvement directly benefits subsequent units.
[HOST]: I see, so it's about compounding knowledge and efficiency. And the fourth?
[MIRA]: The fourth condition is that the output interface must be standardized . What this means is that the product you create can seamlessly plug into the next system or be used directly without requiring individual negotiation, custom adaptation, or bespoke integration every single time. It's designed for interoperability and universal applicability, making it easy to scale its deployment and use.
[HOST]: Let me try to summarize this in my own words to make sure I've got it straight. So, you're saying that if the materials are the same, the method is the same, the experience gained can be directly applied to subsequent units, and the finished product can connect or integrate directly without custom work ， if all four of those conditions are met, then costs can decline exponentially? Is that the core idea?
[MIRA]: That's an excellent summary, you've captured the essence perfectly. These four conditions are central to Wright's Law . Wright's Law states that for every cumulative doubling of production, the unit cost of that product will decrease by a fixed percentage. This isn't just a theoretical concept， this law has been rigorously validated across a wide array of industries, including semiconductors, solar panels, lithium-ion batteries, and genomic sequencing. The stability of this cost curve is so remarkable that, in these specific domains, you can quite reliably predict future costs simply by projecting cumulative production volume. It's a powerful and consistent economic force.
[HOST]: Hold on a second, Wright's Law. I need to ask about that. What's its relationship to Moore's Law, which many people are more familiar with? Are they the same thing, or related?
[MIRA]: That's a great question, and it's important to differentiate them. Moore's Law specifically states that the number of transistors on an integrated circuit roughly doubles every two years. It's primarily a statement about performance and density within the semiconductor industry. Wright's Law, by contrast, is far more general and broadly applicable. It asserts that for any product, whenever its cumulative production output doubles, its unit cost will decrease by a consistent, predictable percentage. So, you could say that Moore's Law is a specific manifestation or a powerful consequence of Wright's Law operating within the semiconductor domain. Wright's Law governs the economic efficiency of production across many industries, not just electronics.
[HOST]: Understood. So, to flip that around, if even just one of those four conditions isn't met, the potential for exponential cost reduction just。 stops? It breaks the chain?
[MIRA]: Exactly. Even if only one of those conditions is broken, the entire accelerating mechanism of exponential cost reduction grinds to a halt. Let's take construction as a prime example. Every single building site is unique. The soil composition varies, the slope of the land is different, the retaining wall of the adjacent property might be a specific challenge, and the local fire regulations can differ from one jurisdiction to the next, even within the same city. So, the first condition， identical inputs ，is fundamentally violated from the outset. You're never starting with a perfectly standardized slate.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's very intuitive. Each house truly does face a unique set of circumstances, even before construction begins. It's not like stamping out identical widgets.
[MIRA]: Now consider healthcare. Every patient is distinct. They have a unique genetic makeup, a singular medical history, varying comorbidities, different lifestyle factors, and individual responses to treatment. Therefore, the treatment process can never be perfectly replicated. A treatment protocol that worked wonders for the previous patient might be completely ineffective, or even harmful, for the next one. This breaks the second condition， a reproducible process . The human body is simply too complex and individual to standardize care to that degree.
[HOST]: What about education? That's another area where costs seem stubbornly high.
[MIRA]: Education is even more fascinating. Each student gets stuck at different points in their learning journey. One student's confusion about a particular mathematical concept might stem from a completely different set of underlying misunderstandings than the next student's. Consequently, the experience and insights gained from teaching one student，the specific analogies that clicked, the particular exercises that helped，are very difficult to directly transfer and apply to the next student in a wholesale manner. This breaks the third condition， the transferable learning curve . The learning isn't cumulative across students in the same way it is in a factory.
[HOST]: Oh, wow. As you list them out like that, it suddenly hits me. Building, healthcare, education，aren't these precisely some of the most expensive and frustrating aspects of our daily lives? The very things we constantly complain about becoming unaffordable? It's like a lightbulb going off.
[MIRA]: Isn't it? And that's precisely the core of the problem. The very domains where we most desperately seek to lower costs，the foundational pillars of a good life，are, by their inherent structure, the most resistant to the forces of exponential growth. They are the areas where factory logic struggles or breaks down entirely. But before we delve deeper into why this happens, I want to introduce an even more fundamental distinction that underpins these observations.
[HOST]: And that's what you mentioned earlier, the distinction between type and token, right? That philosophical concept.
[MIRA]: Exactly. The concept originates from language philosophy, but its applicability extends far beyond linguistics. In simple terms, a type refers to a category or a model that can produce perfectly identical instances. A token, on the other hand, is a specific, particular, concrete occurrence or instance of something. It's a singular event or object that exists in a specific time and place.
[HOST]: That's still a bit abstract for me. Could you give a really clear, concrete example to illustrate the difference? Something very tangible?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Consider the word the in the English language. The, as a lexical entry in a dictionary, representing a specific grammatical function and meaning, is a type . It's the abstract concept. Now, every single time you see the printed in a book, or spoken in a sentence，each individual occurrence of that word，is a token . All these tokens are perfect, indistinguishable reproductions of the same underlying type. They are functionally identical instances of that single type. You can replace one the with another the in a sentence, and no information or meaning is lost.
[HOST]: Ah, I think I'm starting to get it. So, the type is like the blueprint or the master template, and the token is each individual copy or manifestation made from that blueprint? Is that a fair way to think about it?
[MIRA]: You can definitely think of it that way. The crucial point, however, is that some things are inherently types by nature. When you compile a piece of software, for example, every single copy of that software is bit-for-bit identical to every other copy. The software itself is a type . You design it once, and it can be deployed an infinite number of times, with each deployment being a perfect, indistinguishable instance of that type. The cost of copying and distributing these perfect instances approaches zero.
[HOST]: Right, I follow. Software is the quintessential example of a type product.
[MIRA]: But now, consider a building. This specific building, constructed on this particular plot of land, dealing with this unique soil composition, requiring specific permits to align with this particular zoning plan, taking into account that existing retaining wall on the neighboring property, and meticulously adhering to this city's specific fire codes. This particular building is a token . It is designed once, and built once. The next building, on the next plot of land, while it might share some standardized components or construction methods, will involve a unique overall assembly process, a distinct design adaptation, and a bespoke integration with its specific site. The entire process of bringing that particular building into existence is singular and non-replicable.
[HOST]: I understand now. So, you can't just pick up another building and drop it in this exact spot, because on the most important, fundamental level, there simply isn't another identical building. Its unique context makes it irreplaceable and non-fungible.
[MIRA]: You've articulated it perfectly. That's the key mechanism at play. Factory logic can consistently drive down costs for type products precisely because each unit produced is genuinely and perfectly identical to the last. The knowledge gained from manufacturing the one-millionth microchip is 100 applicable to the one-million-and-first. However, if your output is inherently a token, the experience you gained from treating the previous patient can only be partially applied to the next patient. This is because the next patient possesses a unique set of medically relevant characteristics that are, in some aspects, singular. In essence, your learning curve is constantly leaking.
[HOST]: The learning curve is leaking. That's such a vivid and powerful metaphor. It's like trying to fill a bucket that has holes in it ， you're pouring water in, you're putting in effort, but you can't retain it effectively. The accumulated knowledge just drains away instead of building up.
[MIRA]: Precisely. And it's important to understand that this isn't merely a matter of degree， it represents a fundamental phase change .
[HOST]: A phase change? You mean like water turning into ice, a qualitative shift in its nature?
[MIRA]: Exactly, that kind of qualitative, discontinuous leap. A product is either substitutable，meaning one instance can perfectly replace another without any loss of value or information，or it isn't. There's no effective middle ground. Exponential cost reduction, the kind we see in silicon chips, only occurs on the substitutable side of that divide. On the non-substitutable side, at best, you can hope for linear improvements.
[HOST]: What do you mean by linear improvement? Does that just mean it gets a little bit better, slowly, over time?
[MIRA]: Yes, precisely. Linear improvement means you might see incremental gains, a slow, steady increase in efficiency or a modest reduction in cost each year. But it's nothing like the dramatic, compounding effect of exponential growth, where costs might halve this year and halve again next year. And often, in these token domains, you don't even achieve consistent linear improvement. Instead, you frequently encounter a phenomenon known as Baumol's Cost Disease .
[HOST]: Baumol's Cost Disease? What on earth is that? It sounds rather ominous.
[MIRA]: It's a concept put forth by economist William Baumol. In simple terms, it describes a situation where the costs in sectors where productivity growth is inherently difficult to achieve tend to rise continuously over time, relative to the overall economy. Why does this happen? Because in sectors where productivity can grow rapidly, like the technology industry, wages are pushed higher due to that increased productivity. Individuals working in token fields，like teachers, nurses, or construction workers，don't experience the same exponential productivity growth, but their wages still need to keep pace with the rising living standards and wage expectations of society as a whole. Otherwise, those professions simply wouldn't be able to attract and retain talent.
[HOST]: Oh! So, the rising costs in token fields are, in a sense, being pulled up by the falling costs and increasing wages in type fields? It's an indirect consequence of technological progress elsewhere?
[MIRA]: That's precisely the dynamic at play. The more aggressively type industries advance and drive down costs, the more comparatively expensive token industries appear and become. It's not necessarily that token industries are getting worse or less efficient in absolute terms， it's that the relative disparity is widening dramatically. This creates a perception, and indeed a reality, of increasing unaffordability for essential services.
[HOST]: This is truly a counter-intuitive insight. Let me just think about that for a moment. So, the more technology progresses, the more expensive things like seeing a doctor, sending our kids to school, or buying a house feel ? And not just feel, but actually are , in relative terms?
[MIRA]: They feel more expensive, and indeed, in relative terms, they are more expensive. This isn't an illusion or a trick of perception. This is a fundamental, structural reality of how different economic sectors interact under these conditions. The exponential gains in one area create a ripple effect that makes non-exponential areas appear, and become, disproportionately costly.
[HOST]: Alright, I want to test this framework with some concrete examples. You briefly touched on construction earlier， could you elaborate on that and explain how the type token distinction applies there?
[MIRA]: Construction is an excellent case study because, on the surface, it often appears to be an industry ripe for exponential growth. After all, if you look at many of its constituent parts，prefabricated components, standardized wood frames, engineered trusses, drywall sheets, insulation，these are all classic type products. They are manufactured in factories, often with increasing efficiency, and their individual costs are indeed decreasing over time.
[HOST]: Exactly! That's what always puzzled me. If all these individual components are getting cheaper, why isn't the cost of the entire house coming down along with them? Where's the disconnect?
[MIRA]: The disconnect lies in the fact that the process of assembling these standardized components into a specific, unique building on a specific, unique site is inherently token work. You have to deal with the particularities of that plot of land， how to lay the foundation on this specific slope, how to manage drainage to avoid that neighbor's property, how to navigate this city's specific building codes and inspection requirements. These are all one-off challenges that change with every project. So, the cost reductions achieved at the type level, for the individual components, are largely absorbed and outweighed by the persistent, non-exponential costs incurred at the token level of site-specific integration and assembly.
[HOST]: Hmm, I see. So, while the prefabricated wall panels might be cheaper to produce in the factory, the cost of the skilled labor to install them, the coordination required on a dynamic job site, and the bespoke fitting to the unique foundation and local conditions ， those costs haven't really decreased, or perhaps have even increased.
[MIRA]: Precisely. And this explains why, despite over a century of innovation and advocacy for prefabricated housing, it has never generated the kind of exponential cost reduction seen in other manufacturing sectors. The type components continue to become more affordable, but the token work of integrating them into a unique, site-specific structure will never decline exponentially. It's a fundamental limitation of the output's structure.
[HOST]: Okay, what about healthcare? I recall you mentioning in your article that healthcare splits very cleanly along this type token line. Can you illustrate that?
[MIRA]: It's an exceptionally clean split. Consider medical imaging diagnostics, for example, like the interpretation of a CT scan. The same sophisticated A I algorithm can process virtually every scan, identifying patterns, anomalies, and ultimately outputting a classification or a preliminary diagnosis. This is a highly standardized, repeatable, and scalable type operation. And indeed, the cost of processing and interpreting medical images is becoming increasingly cheaper and more accurate, especially with A I advancements.
[HOST]: Yes, I've definitely noticed that. A I's ability to analyze medical scans is already quite impressive and getting better all the time. It feels like a genuine breakthrough.
[MIRA]: It is. But now, consider the entire clinical consultation process. The doctor needs to gather and understand this specific patient's comprehensive medical history, consider their lifestyle, perform a differential diagnosis based on their unique symptoms, account for any pre-existing conditions, assess their insurance situation, and then formulate a personalized treatment plan that is appropriate for them . Each consultation is a uniquely configured, bespoke interaction. This is unequivocally token work. It requires nuanced human judgment, empathy, and adaptation to an individual's complex reality.
[HOST]: So, the imaging part gets cheaper, but the overall cost of seeing a doctor doesn't necessarily go down? In fact, it might even go up?
[MIRA]: If you look at the statistical data, you'll observe precisely that trend. The cost of medical imaging services，the type layer，has indeed been falling or at least stabilizing. Yet, overall healthcare expenditure continues its relentless upward climb. The cost savings achieved in the type layer are effectively absorbed and often overshadowed by the persistent or increasing costs in the token layer of personalized care, clinical judgment, and human interaction. It's a zero-sum game within the system, where savings in one area are offset by growth in another.
[HOST]: This makes me think about something a lot of people are talking about now. Many predict that A I is going to completely revolutionize healthcare, leading to a massive reduction in costs. How do you view that through your framework?
[MIRA]: Actually, in my article, I made a very specific prediction regarding A I's impact on healthcare. I anticipate that within five years, A I's diagnostic accuracy in radiology will surpass that of the average human radiologist. This will, without a doubt, lead to a significant reduction in the cost of medical imaging. However, I also predict that the overall, aggregate healthcare expenditure will not decrease as a result.
[HOST]: It won't decrease? Why not? That seems to fly in the face of what many experts are saying about A I's potential.
[MIRA]: Because the money saved in the type layer，the automated diagnosis of images，will be absorbed by the token layer. That includes complex care coordination, nuanced treatment decisions, empathetic patient communication, and the intricate process of planning specific, individualized therapies. These are all fundamentally token tasks. A I can be incredibly powerful in its designated domains, but as long as the ultimate output must be customized for a specific, unique human case, the cost of that customization will not decline exponentially. The human element of care, the bespoke judgment, remains stubbornly expensive.
[HOST]: Ugh, that's a bit disheartening, to be honest. So, no matter how advanced A I becomes, healthcare won't become significantly cheaper overall? That's a tough pill to swallow for many who envision a future of universally affordable medical care.
[MIRA]: Well, I wouldn't say it won't change at all . Rather, the nature and direction of the change will be different from what many people anticipate. A I won't bring about a widespread, exponential collapse in overall healthcare costs. Instead, it will create a pronounced tier separation. The type layer of medical services will become extraordinarily cheap, while the token layer will remain expensive, or even become relatively more so. The proportion of costs attributed to each layer will shift dramatically, but the fundamental exemption for token work will persist.
[HOST]: Hmm, now that you put it that way, I suddenly realize this framework would apply to the field of education as well, wouldn't it? It seems to fit perfectly.
[MIRA]: It applies exceptionally well. You can see this clearly in the development of online education. The core educational content，textbooks, lecture videos, interactive modules，these are all type products. The price of textbooks, especially in their digital format, has plummeted. Video lectures can be scaled and distributed infinitely at near-zero marginal cost.
[HOST]: Right, and there are so many high-quality, free online courses available now. You can learn almost anything from a top university without paying a dime for the content itself.
[MIRA]: Exactly. But now, consider the phenomenon of Massive Open Online Courses, or MOOCs.
[HOST]: MOOCs? What does that acronym stand for again?
[MIRA]: MOOC stands for Massive Open Online Course. These are university-level courses offered online, often for free, to an unlimited number of participants. You might be familiar with platforms like Coursera or edX. They take lectures from prestigious universities, put them online, and literally millions of people can access them simultaneously. On paper, it sounds like the perfect solution for democratizing education and dramatically lowering costs, doesn't it?
[HOST]: Absolutely, it sounds like an incredible step towards educational equity and accessibility. A truly wonderful development for society.
[MIRA]: But can you guess what their typical completion rates are? They generally hover somewhere between five and fifteen percent.
[HOST]: That low? Are you serious? That's shockingly low for something with such high potential! What explains such a massive drop-off?
[MIRA]: It's true. And the reason lies precisely in our framework. MOOCs perfectly scale the type layer，the course content itself. They make knowledge infinitely reproducible and distributable. But they completely strip away the token layer of education. What is that token layer? It's the personalized teaching relationship. It's this specific student , at this particular moment , struggling with this precise conceptual misunderstanding . That interaction is unique and bespoke. You can distribute lecture videos for free, but you cannot distribute personalized tutoring for free. The human connection, the tailored feedback, the individual motivation，those are inherently token and thus expensive.
[HOST]: You can distribute videos for free, but you can't distribute tutors for free. That's such a powerful and concise way to put it. It perfectly encapsulates the challenge.
[MIRA]: Indeed. In fact, this single insight captures the core dilemma that the entire educational technology industry has grappled with over the past decade. Companies have tirelessly attempted to transform the inherently token process of personalized teaching into a scalable, type product. But they haven't succeeded, not because of a lack of effort or innovation, but because the fundamental structure of the desired output simply doesn't allow for it. You can't make something inherently unique into something perfectly replicable without losing its essential value.
[HOST]: Okay, now I want to ask a question that might be a little provocative, or maybe even challenge your framework slightly. You said earlier that this dividing line isn't drawn between digital and physical things, right? But semiconductors and software are clearly type products and are digital or highly automated, while construction, healthcare, and education definitely involve the physical world and human interaction. How do you definitively prove that this isn't simply a distinction between digital and physical?
[MIRA]: That's an excellent and crucial question, and it's one I anticipated. Let's look at solar panels. A solar panel is 100 a physical product, made of silicon, glass, and a metal frame. Yet, it is a type product. Every single solar panel produced from a given design is a perfect instance of that design. They are designed for mass production, consistent output, and interchangeable use. Consequently, the cost curve for solar panels, much like semiconductors, has exhibited a dramatic exponential decline over decades. It's a physical product, but it behaves like a type.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's a strong counter-example to the digital physical argument.
[MIRA]: Or consider a pharmaceutical pill. It's a chemical molecule, a completely physical product. But once that specific molecule has been discovered, developed, and approved, every single pill manufactured from that formula is identical. It is a type. Therefore, the cost of producing these standardized pharmaceutical drugs can also decline exponentially due to economies of scale and factory logic. Of course, the process of discovering a new drug is a highly bespoke, R D-intensive token process, but the manufacturing once the drug is found is a type.
[HOST]: Oh, so physical products can indeed ride the exponential growth express, as long as they are fundamentally types in your framework? That really does clarify the distinction.
[MIRA]: Precisely. Lithium-ion batteries are another example， each individual cell is a perfect instance of a standardized design. Genomic sequencing also fits this pattern， the same standardized set of laboratory procedures and computational algorithms can process every single biological sample. These are all inherently physical operations, involving complex machinery and materials, yet because their outputs are type products，perfectly replicable and substitutable，their cost curves have all shown remarkable exponential decline. The underlying physical reality doesn't prevent exponential cost reduction if the product itself is a type.
[HOST]: Understood. So, the key truly isn't whether something is digital or physical, but whether your product can be perfectly replicated, or more accurately, perfectly substituted for another instance without losing its essential value. That's the core differentiator.
[MIRA]: To be more precise, it's about whether your output is substitutable . Can one instance of the product or service be replaced by another instance without any loss of functionality, quality, or essential value? If the answer is yes, then you are firmly on the side of exponential growth. If the answer is no，if each instance is unique and tailored to a specific situation，then you are not. That simple test reveals which side of the dividing line an industry falls on.
[HOST]: This also helps explain why so many people are predicting that A I will disrupt everything and make things unbelievably cheap, but in reality, that might not be the case across the board? It puts a critical lens on that broad optimism.
[MIRA]: To be frank, that's one of the primary motivations behind writing this article. There are currently far too many generalized predictions about A I, often claiming that it will drive all costs towards zero. But if you analyze A I's impact through the type and token framework, you quickly realize that its influence is highly structured and uneven, not a uniform wave washing over all industries equally. A I will certainly be transformative, but its transformation will be targeted and specific.
[HOST]: How do you mean, structured? Can you elaborate on that?
[MIRA]: When A I enters a token domain, its benefits and cost reductions will disproportionately concentrate on the type sub-layers within that token domain. For example, in healthcare, A I can dramatically lower the cost of interpreting medical images, because image interpretation is a standardized, type operation. However, it will struggle to significantly reduce the overall cost of a full clinical consultation, because the core of that consultation，the empathetic interaction, the nuanced judgment, the personalized treatment plan，is fundamentally token work. A I can optimize the inputs to human judgment, but it doesn't replace the judgment itself, especially when that judgment is bespoke.
[HOST]: Wait, I want to make sure I'm crystal clear on this. Are you suggesting that every so-called token industry actually contains a mix of type sub-layers and token sub-layers within it? That it's not a pure dichotomy?
[MIRA]: Yes, yes, exactly! That's a very astute observation and a crucial nuance. No complex industry is purely type or purely token. They are all hybrids. Within healthcare, for instance, imaging analysis is a type layer, while clinical judgment and patient-specific care planning constitute the token layer. In education, the curriculum content and lecture materials are the type layer, but the personalized teacher-student interaction and guidance are the token layer. And in construction, prefabricated components are the type layer, but the on-site assembly and integration are the token layer. This mixed nature is critical to understanding A I's specific impact.
[HOST]: So, A I's primary function in these fields is to drive down the costs of those type sub-layers within the larger token industry? Is that its main contribution?
[MIRA]: Precisely. A I can, and will, drive down the costs of those type sub-layers, often to incredibly low levels, approaching zero marginal cost for certain tasks. But the token sub-layers will remain largely unaffected in terms of their fundamental cost structure. So, the overall effect isn't a widespread, exponential collapse of all costs. Instead, it's a dramatic and often counter-intuitive redistribution of costs, where the expenditure becomes increasingly concentrated on the token layers. The parts that can be cheap become extremely cheap, but the parts that are inherently bespoke remain expensive. The cost ratios shift, but the exemption for token work persists.
[HOST]: You mentioned exemption earlier. Is that the concept from the title of your article?
[MIRA]: Yes, that's what I refer to as the Exponential Exemption . It's the inherent characteristic of token domains to be naturally exempt from exponential cost reduction. This isn't because we lack intelligence, or because we haven't invested enough resources, or because we're not trying hard enough. It's because the fundamental structure of the output，its inherent uniqueness and non-replicability，simply does not permit it. It's a boundary condition, not a problem to be solved through sheer effort.
[HOST]: You brought up the legal industry earlier. Can you expand on how this framework applies there? It's another profession often seen as ripe for A I disruption.
[MIRA]: The legal profession is another classic example where this distinction shines brightly. Consider tasks like document review for litigation or due diligence, or even basic legal research for common precedents. These are highly standardized, pattern-matching, type operations. An A I system can sift through millions of documents, identify relevant clauses, and flag anomalies in minutes，a task that would take a team of human lawyers weeks, if not months, to complete. The cost for these type tasks will undoubtedly plummet, potentially by orders of magnitude.
[HOST]: So, A I will make things like reviewing contracts or e-discovery much cheaper. But what about the overall cost of, say, a full-blown lawsuit or complex legal counsel? Will that come down as well?
[MIRA]: My prediction is that the overall cost of litigation and high-level legal strategy will not significantly decrease, and may even, in relative terms, increase. Why? Because trial preparation, courtroom advocacy, negotiation with opposing counsel, and the nuanced judgment required in tailoring arguments to specific judges, juries, and client circumstances，these are all fundamentally token work. Every case has its unique factual matrix, every judge has their individual style, every jury panel is composed differently, every negotiation involves unique human psychology. These are not situations you can address with a single, replicable template. While the type work of document review becomes incredibly cheap, the token costs associated with human strategy, persuasion, and bespoke legal judgment will likely remain stubbornly high, or even become the dominant cost component.
[HOST]: Wow, that's a pretty bold prediction. If that future really plays out, a lot of people's expectations for A I's impact on the legal system might be profoundly unmet. It challenges the popular narrative quite a bit.
[MIRA]: Well, I wouldn't say unmet as much as in need of adjustment. A I will indeed bring about immense changes, but the shape of those changes won't be what many people envision. It won't be a uniform tidal wave that indiscriminately washes away costs across all domains. Instead, it will be more like a powerful, focused current that, within each domain, compresses the compressible layers to an extreme degree, thereby exposing and highlighting the layers that are inherently incompressible.
[HOST]: Exposing the incompressible layers. That's a very evocative way of putting it. It's like the tide receding, and only then do you truly see where the hidden rocks and reefs are beneath the surface.
[MIRA]: Yes, I think that analogy works quite well. A I is that receding tide. It will force us to see, with unprecedented clarity, what is truly expensive, truly difficult, and truly irreplaceable within each industry. It shifts the focus from what can be automated to what must remain human and bespoke.
[HOST]: That leads me to a broader, perhaps even existential, question. If your framework is correct, how should we, as a society, think about the most pressing and expensive challenges we face，healthcare, education, housing, legal services? Should we change our approach entirely?
[MIRA]: That's a question I grapple with constantly, and to be honest, I don't have a perfect, definitive answer. But I believe the critical first step is to honestly and unequivocally confront this fundamental boundary condition. These industries are expensive not because people are necessarily doing things wrong, not primarily because of excessive regulation, or even a lack of innovation. They are expensive because the fundamental structure of their output is token in nature.
[HOST]: Hmm, that acceptance of the inherent nature of the problem seems crucial.
[MIRA]: When you truly internalize this point, you stop chasing phantom silver bullets. You no longer expect that some singular new technology，whether it's A I, blockchain, or whatever comes next，will suddenly slash healthcare costs by 90 . Because it's not a technological problem in the conventional sense， it's a geometrical problem .
[HOST]: A geometrical problem? What do you mean by that? That's a fascinating choice of words.
[MIRA]: I mean the inherent geometrical structure of the output itself. Whether your product can be perfectly replicated and substituted is determined by its very essence, by its fundamental nature, not by the specific technology you use to produce it. You cannot, through cleverer methods or more advanced tools, transform an inherently token output into a type output. This is because the very characteristics that make it a token，its bespoke nature, its tailored fit, its unique responsiveness to an individual situation，are precisely those features that give it profound value to specific human beings. To strip away its token nature would be to strip away its value.
[HOST]: Whoa, hold on a second. Could you repeat that last sentence? That really hit me.
[MIRA]: The very characteristics that make an output a token are precisely those features that give it profound value to specific human beings. The fact that this patient is different from that patient isn't a bug in the healthcare system， it is the fundamental premise of providing effective medical care. The fact that this student struggles with a concept in a way unique to them isn't an inefficiency of education， it is the very reason education exists and needs to be personalized. These are not flaws to be engineered away.
[HOST]: That really does reframe so many things for me. It means that the token-ness, the individual, bespoke nature, isn't a problem to be solved. It is the value itself. That's a powerful shift in perspective.
[MIRA]: Exactly. You can, and should, reduce the costs of the type layers embedded within these token domains. Making medical imaging cheaper, offering free foundational course content, automating document review，these are all incredibly valuable advancements. But you cannot realistically expect to drive the overall costs of these entire fields down to near zero. Because you cannot effectively compress or eliminate the unique individuality of each human being they serve. That's the irreducible core.
[HOST]: So, returning to A I companies. Many A I startups, when they're pitching for funding, will often declare that they're going to use A I to disrupt healthcare, disrupt education, disrupt law, making them radically cheaper. Do you think they are being disingenuous, or are they perhaps deluding themselves?
[MIRA]: Actually, I believe the vast majority are not being disingenuous. I think they genuinely believe that exponential growth, fueled by technology, can and should extend limitlessly into all domains. This perspective often stems from their own background. They typically come from type industries，software development, chip manufacturing, digital platforms，where they have witnessed firsthand the miracles of exponential growth and near-zero marginal costs. So, it's an instinctive belief for them that if the technology is powerful enough, everything can eventually be exponentialized. They are extrapolating from their lived experience.
[HOST]: But you're saying that's fundamentally incorrect.
[MIRA]: It is incorrect. You cannot exponentially scale something that cannot be perfectly replicated. This isn't a technological limitation that a smarter algorithm can overcome， it's a fundamental logical constraint. It's like saying you can't become two people simply by running faster. The problem of speed and the problem of quantity are entirely distinct. You can optimize the quality of a single instance, but you cannot make that single instance two instances just by making it better.
[HOST]: Haha, that's a brilliant analogy. You can't become two people simply by running faster. I'll remember that one.
[MIRA]: But I want to emphasize that I'm not saying A I is useless in these fields. Far from it. A I can accomplish a tremendous amount in these token domains. It can drive down the cost of the type sub-layers to incredibly low levels. It can free up the time and cognitive energy of human experts, allowing them to focus their precious attention on the truly bespoke, token judgments that only humans can make. This, in itself, is an enormous and invaluable contribution to human well-being and efficiency.
[HOST]: Right, it's about calibrating expectations, then. Understanding where A I truly excels and where its limitations lie.
[MIRA]: Precisely. You shouldn't expect A I to make seeing a doctor as free as conducting a web search. But you can expect A I to enable your doctor to spend significantly more time talking with you, understanding your specific circumstances, and engaging in nuanced clinical reasoning, rather than spending their time interpreting standard imaging or sifting through mountains of data. That personalized conversation, that bespoke human judgment，that will still cost money. And it likely always will.
[HOST]: You know, Mira, I have a mental image now. It's like every industry is an iceberg. The part above the water, the type layer, that's what A I can rapidly melt away, making it incredibly cheap. But the part below the water, the token layer, that remains stubbornly there, and you don't see it shrinking.
[MIRA]: And what's more, once the part above the water has melted away, the part below the water often appears even larger. Because now, it constitutes a significantly higher percentage of the total cost. The relative proportion shifts dramatically.
[HOST]: Yes! So, the more successful A I becomes at automating the type work, the more expensive token work will appear to be, in proportion? That's a fascinating, and somewhat unsettling, consequence.
[MIRA]: That's another manifestation of Baumol's Cost Disease, playing out in the A I era. A I automates everything that can be automated，the type tasks. What's left over, the tasks that must be performed by humans, requiring bespoke judgment and interaction, become the most expensive and critical bottlenecks in the entire system. You'll find yourself wondering, How can A I be so incredibly powerful, and yet seeing a doctor still costs so much? The answer is that the truly expensive, irreplaceable part，the token part，is precisely what A I cannot touch in terms of its fundamental cost structure.
[HOST]: That makes me think about another big question people are asking， the concern that A I will replace various jobs. How should we understand that concern through your framework?
[MIRA]: If your job primarily involves type operations，for example, standardized document review, routine data analysis, repetitive diagnostics, or generating boilerplate content，then you are indeed facing significant pressure from A I automation and potential replacement. However, if the core of your work involves token judgment，meaning you are faced with unique situations and required to make bespoke decisions tailored to those specific circumstances，then A I is far more likely to serve as a powerful tool to augment your capabilities rather than to replace you entirely. It will enhance your capacity for unique judgment, not eliminate the need for it.
[HOST]: So, the crucial factor is whether you're performing type tasks or token tasks in your job. That determines your vulnerability or augmentation potential.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And it's important to recognize that most jobs are actually a mix. A doctor, for instance, might spend thirty percent of their time on type work, such as interpreting routine scans or reviewing standardized patient data. The other seventy percent is spent on token work， communicating with patients, performing nuanced clinical examinations, making complex diagnostic judgments, and providing empathetic support. A I will likely absorb and optimize that thirty percent of type work, making the doctor more efficient, and allowing them to spend more of their time on the seventy percent of token work. It enhances rather than eliminates.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's a far more precise and nuanced prediction than the generalized statements about A I replacing X million jobs. It gives a much clearer picture of the actual impact.
[MIRA]: I believe the inaccuracy of many A I impact predictions stems precisely from their failure to distinguish between type and token. They tend to evaluate an entire industry as a monolithic entity and ask whether A I can replace it . But in reality, you need to disaggregate each industry, identify its specific type layers and token layers, and then determine which layers A I can profoundly impact and which it fundamentally cannot. This granular analysis yields far more accurate and actionable insights.
[HOST]: Alright, let's move to our final question for today. In the very last sentence of your article, you state that the exponential exemption isn't a problem to be solved， it's a boundary condition. Tokens do not compound. Can you explain to our listeners what that profound statement means for them in their everyday lives and choices?
[MIRA]: It means we need to accept a fundamental truth about value and cost. Some things are inherently destined to be expensive, precisely because their value to you derives from their bespoke, tailored nature. Your education isn't a mass-produced commodity. Your medical care isn't a standardized part number. The home you live in isn't pulled from a generic catalog. They are expensive because they are yours , specifically crafted or delivered for your unique circumstances and needs. Their individuality is their value proposition.
[HOST]: Hmm. The personal connection makes them inherently costly.
[MIRA]: I believe the most constructive attitude isn't one of anger or indignation，asking why can't these things be cheaper? Instead, it's about understanding this underlying structural reality and then making more intelligent choices within that structure. This means diligently saving money wherever possible in the type layers, leveraging all available technologies to make those components as efficient and inexpensive as possible. And then, crucially, redirecting those saved resources to invest wisely in the token layers，the parts that truly require human judgment, empathy, and bespoke attention. It's about not pursuing the wrong kind of efficiency in the wrong layer.
[HOST]: Do not pursue the wrong kind of efficiency in the wrong layer. That's a powerful maxim. It could be a guiding principle for so many aspects of life and business.
[MIRA]: Ha, thank you. Though, to be entirely honest, I'm still pondering this question myself. There are aspects I'm not entirely certain about. For example, will A I ever become so powerful that it can truly handle genuine token judgment in a way that fundamentally alters its cost structure? In my article, I argue it won't, due to the inherent output structure. But truthfully, I only have about seventy or eighty percent confidence in that particular judgment.
[HOST]: You said seventy or eighty percent confidence. What's occupying the other twenty or thirty percent of your thought process? What are the edge cases or possibilities you're still considering?
[MIRA]: I'm considering what would happen if, hypothetically, A I could one day truly understand every unique facet of a token situation, and could consistently make every bespoke judgment as well as, or even better than, a human expert. From a purely technical standpoint, perhaps that's conceivable in the distant future. But even if it could achieve that quality of token judgment, the cost structure might still not change. Because the sheer computational demand and the level of attention required to process each unique token might inherently resist exponential scaling down. You're still dealing with distinct, non-fungible problems.
[HOST]: Because each individual token requires independent, dedicated processing, and you simply can't batch-process uniqueness?
[MIRA]: Exactly. It's akin to this， even if you hired the single smartest tutor in the world, capable of delivering the absolute best personalized instruction, they can still only teach one student at a time. They can teach better , but they cannot simultaneously teach a million students, because each student's needs, learning style, and specific points of confusion are unique. Intelligence solves the problem of quality , but it doesn't solve the problem of quantity when dealing with inherently unique instances. And exponential cost reduction fundamentally requires quantity through replicability.
[HOST]: Intelligence solves quality, but not quantity. That's a fantastic point, and I think that's a perfect place to bring today's conversation to a close. To leave our listeners with something to ponder, perhaps you could offer a final question for them?
[MIRA]: Absolutely. The next time you find yourself thinking that a particular industry is too expensive, too backward, or insufficiently innovative, try asking yourself one simple question， Is what this industry provides you something that could be perfectly replaced by another identical instance? Or is it something you value precisely because it is specifically tailored to your unique situation? If the answer is the latter, then that industry might not be doing anything fundamentally wrong. It's simply doing something that, by its very nature, will never become exponentially cheaper. And then, extend that thinking to your own work and life， Which of your contributions are type work, and which are token work? And where does your truly scarce, truly valuable contribution ultimately lie?
[HOST]: Wow. That's a profound thought to end on. Alright, that's all for today. Thank you, Mira. This has been incredibly enlightening.
[MIRA]: Thank you, it's been a truly enjoyable and stimulating conversation.
[HOST]: And to all our listeners, we'll see you next time. If today's episode resonated with you or sparked some new ideas, please feel free to share it with your friends and colleagues. Especially those working in architecture, healthcare, or education，I imagine they'll find a lot to relate to in this discussion.
[MIRA]: Yes, and please do feel free to leave comments on Substack or wherever you listen and let us know your thoughts. I'm genuinely curious to hear where you draw the type and token dividing line within your own respective industries.
[HOST]: Alright, see you next time.
[MIRA]: See you next time.